the question of Free Will is linked to a
materialist metaphysics like people
worrying that oh if my choices are
determined by the patterns of brain
activity in my brain then I don't have
free will well on that account I think
people need not be afraid because I
don't think physiological patterns of
brain activity cause your choices I
think they are what your choices look
like in schopenhauer's terminology they
are appearances
representations uh the thing in itself
is your choice so no your choices are
not determined by your brain activity
your brain activity is what the process
of making choices look like and then you
would say well then I am endorsing Free
Will well now we have now to understand
what people mean by Free Will what
people mean by it is that their choices
are determined by that which they
identify themselves with as opposed to
being determined by something that they
don't identify with